[Music]
My name is Rohit Turri. I am a member of
the foundation model training and
inference team at AWS. And we have an
amazing talk. Super super awesome
founder here talking about voice AI. So
Arjun, why don't you go ahead? Awesome.
Well, thanks for the intro, Ro. Uh, I'm
Arjun. I'm one of the co-founders of
Cartisia AI. Uh you know I'll give you a
little bit of a spiel about what we do
which is that you know we build
real-time multimodal intelligence that
runs on any device. Um so maybe you know
the topic of this conversation will be
focused a little bit more on how do we
build voice AI for enterprise. As many
of you know, voice AI is, you know,
definitely up and coming and one of the
places where, you know, having
interactive models is really critical
for being able to get really uh good
experience uh for uh your, you know,
agents.
So, just a little bit of a recap, right?
When you think about foundation models,
you know, we often think about, you
know, models are hosted in the cloud,
really large, you know, they're doing
things kind of in batch mode, right? you
know, you submit a request and then you
might get something back. You know,
you're not going to get it back 30
seconds later, but you might get it
back, you know, in 500, 600
milliseconds. And, you know, that's
okay, right? Typically for text, you
know, you're not also going to be
reading uh at speeds of like 200 tokens
per second. Uh, and so it's okay if you
know there's a little bit of a delay and
then you get high throughput later. But
when you think about interactive
applications like video and voice
especially, this is an incredible
visceral experience that you're giving
to your users. Speed is of the utmost
importance and quality is just table
stakes.
So at Cartisia, we're really trying to
change the paradigm of how we think
about foundation models to not just be
like in the cloud what you build for
batch operations, but actually how you
bring bring it to real time, have it
cover multiple modalities. And we'll be
talking more about voice today and have
it run anywhere on the in the world, not
just on the cloud, but on any device.
So, because we're talking a little bit
about voice, I want to maybe give a
little bit of a prelude why it's so
important to think about speed. Imagine
you're having a conversation with the
person next to you. Uh, and you probably
should do that after this talk. But, uh,
I think the main thing is that it would
feel really awkward, right, if you were
trying to talk to someone and they
responded a second later. So, in voice,
you don't have seconds to actually give
your response back. You have
milliseconds. And when you think about
voice agents where you might be calling,
you know, customer support on the line
trying to triage your problem, you're
going to get pretty annoyed if it's not
responding to you and giving you
accurate results as soon as possible. So
when you think about voice, you have to
deal with things like interruptions. You
have to think about globalization. These
things relate to accents, right?
Background noises that you might be
calling from. And at the end of the day,
when you actually want to deliver this
experience, it's incredibly subjective.
So there's so many nuances and
customizations that you want around
voice.
So what we've done at Cartisia is really
thought about building solutions for
voice AI on the modeling side from first
principles. We care about three things.
The first is quality. The naturalness of
the voice must be exquisite and
something that is just table stakes for
the kinds of experiences that you want
to be able to deliver. The second is
latency. You want to be able to hear the
first bite or the first sound of audio
on the other line as soon as possible.
This gives your end-to-end agent a lot
more time to be able to do things like
reason more, right? And have a little
bit more slack in the endto-end system.
And third, arguably most important, is
controllability. The experience that you
want to exude by having an agent
customized for the things that you want
to do is a reflection of your brand. You
want the agent to be able to talk about
what your company is or what you're
trying to sell in the way that you
would. So being able to customize the
voice AI to be able to do this is
critical and paramount to being able to
deliver a great experience to your user.
So what we've done is we've pioneered a
new architecture called state space
models. These are an alternative to
transformers. And the main takeaway here
is that typically transformers scale
quadratically. Which means the longer
your inputs get, you get quadratic
scaling in your memory as well as in
your uh in your runtime. So you know the
longer your inputs, the slower your
models get. With state based models or
SSM generation at inference time is O of
one. We maintain a state that you can
generate from and this means that you
have perfect very low latency things
that you can't achieve with traditional
transformer architectures. What we've
pioneered is that these stateates space
based models typically have been, you
know, lower performing in the recurrent
sense compared to transformers, but
we've closed that gap and our models
actually perform not just better from a
latency perspective, but also from a
quality perspective.
So, I can give a little bit of a spiel
about, you know, why this matters, but I
think we're more interested in having
more of a conversation around voice AI.
So, Ro, why don't you kick us off?
Definitely. So, just so you all know,
this was supposed to be a fireside chat.
We had some chairs and asking some good
questions. So we're going to open it up
to the audience in a little bit. I do
have a few questions for you. Arjun
talked a little bit about latency. We
hear voice AI challenges like quality
and let's say the speed of the models as
mentioned the way that they're hosted on
the edge etc. What are the challenges
that like your customers are facing why
are you building for this? Yeah. So uh I
think the main thing is that you know
when you do voice AI and you know main
model that we have is Sonic 2 which is
focused on voice generation. That's one
part of the puzzle. you have to actually
trying to build voice agents. You have
to hook it up with the LM. You have to
hook it up with your speech to text
model. And the biggest issue honestly is
that there's not enough time. You need
your LM to actually have a lot of time.
You know, these models aren't typically
built for, you know, high uh or low
latency workflows. And so, you want to
actually give it the most slack. So,
latency is, you know, of utmost
importance there. And I can talk a
little bit about, you know, what we've
done to create the fastest model in the
world for text to speech. Uh the second
I'd say is controllability. So, you
know, one thing that we've noticed so
much is people use our platform because
you're able to get amazing quality
around things like voice cloning,
accents, being able to capture
background noises just so natively in
the generations that you want. You know,
people think it's like a little bit of
an uncanny valley when you're talking to
an agent and it just sounds perfect.
They like the little phone noises in the
background, little beep boops, right?
You know, that's kind of what you like
to hear, right? Or what you expect,
right, when you're on a phone call. Uh,
so I think those are the two main things
that I' I'd like to say that, you know,
we've done a really amazing job of
getting nailing those down. Yeah. And
you mentioned something interesting
there, a couple of the use cases, right?
Voice cloning, right? The control of the
voices, etc. Can you talk a little bit
about the customer use cases you're
seeing today of voice AI? Yeah, so you
know, voice AI honestly has penetrated
so much so many markets out here. We
look at healthcare, customer support.
Uh, a lot of this is actually going into
real-time gaming, right? When you're
dealing with non-player characters, you
want them to be dynamic, interact, you
know, with the, uh, players of the game.
Um these are you know three of many many
markets that you know voice AI has
started to grow in. Uh and you know I
think what's really exciting is that
because it's growing so fast. You know
it's just so great to have partners like
AWS who are also you know investing in
that space and being like look you know
these are things that we need to support
naturally um and you know people want to
use our platform for. Yeah. What about
human narration right I think we hear a
lot about uh like voice AI taking over
different types of industries or these
use cases as mentioned. Do you see a
place for human narrative narrators in
the future as well? Definitely. Yeah.
You know, creators are a huge part of
the voice AI platform. I think one thing
that I think we do a really got good job
of is we actually have like a voice
marketplace for creators, right? You
know, why is this so important? You
know, our goal is not to, you know,
replace voice actors actually. It's not
what I want to do at all. I think my
main goal is like how do you give them a
platform so that their, you know, their
um I forgot what like their essence,
right? You know, who they are, their
personality can actually be exuded and
like, you know, licensed by other people
that want to use the platform. Um and so
you know this actually gives you know
we've had a lot of voice actors on board
on our platform you know a great way of
amplifying them uh and yeah a lot of use
cases are honestly focused on narration
as well. Got it. So I have a few more
questions. Maybe we'll end with them.
Does anybody have questions in the
crowd? Anything about voice AI?
Yeah question. I feel this might be a
dumb question but I'm gonna ask. No
please. I've just started using
Cartisia. It's like it's a game changer
framework.
because there's an Amazon partnership
here. I was just wondering like claw
doesn't seem to work so well because of
the latency. Okay. Is that is that
normal? What are the models that you
usually pair with and is there is there
plans for can you repeat the question on
your end just so that sure? Yeah. Yeah.
So, uh the question was you know um
we're cartisia's integrated with pipecat
you know pipcat cartisia we both you
know work with AWS but cloud you know
still has you know pretty high latency
when you're trying to you know do things
end to end. Uh so you know this is you
know a huge huge problem right this is
why you know the slack that we give you
on the TTS side is something you know
you can account for on the LM side uh
I'll let Ro you know take a stab at that
question but I know that like you know
claude and you know other um other
models like you know have different you
know mechanisms for you know you can
have like a dedicated instance that's
running so you can get like you know
better latency numbers um you know but a
lot of this is actually just you know
it's it's up to you know the LM
providers often right to make these
optimizations I think one thing that you
know we're really excited about is our
goal is to you know make real time AI
pervasive, right? Uh and so, you know,
we're really excited about if there's
like certain applications that, you
know, you're really after, you know, how
can we enable you to do that? So, happy
to chat, you know, after this talk.
Yeah, of course. And I'll add a couple
things to that, too. What's really
amazing about Cartisia and their
background is the development of custom
model architectures specifically for
this use case, which is voice AI, and we
spoke a little bit about SSM and linear
scaling versus quadratic scaling. One
thing from the AWS side and what I think
is really amazing about our design
philosophy for our generative AI
ecosystem is we want customers to have
optionality in this in our platform and
if you look at AWS's model model gardens
we have SageMaker Jumpstart and Amazon
Bedrock these model gardens will have a
host of different types of models for
specific types of use cases and we're on
the lookout for the next foundation
model provider one like cartisia that we
can bring into our ecosystem and unlock
downstream industries that might be
underserved by the existing foundation
models today. So that's part of our
strategy, part of our philosophy. And I
think what and I'll say it again with
Cartisia, we're really unlocking the
voice AI. We need real-time AI. We need
we need the ability to host on edge
devices and uh we're unlocking a lot of
customers with their models. So
hopefully that answers a little bit. A
little bit. Yeah, we can chat a little
bit more after. Yeah. Yeah.
I have some friends that are
researching
that video
that you know you don't need so much
scale of actual video data but rather
the density of information per frame of
that video
I'm curious if there's something similar
in voice data whether you believe that
to achieve next level models you need
the next scale of data or is it more
aboutity
of that. Yeah, that's a good question.
And so I think the question uh was more
around the lines of like you know how
does voice AI data you know compared to
you know some of the other multimodal
data sets in video you know one of the
prevailing theories uh was that um you
know you don't um actually need a lot of
data you just need it to be very rich
right and you know if that's the same in
voice AI uh I think the short answer to
that is uh yes but also no um I think
like when you think about scaling for a
lot of models you know the generative uh
you know in generative AI right the
general philosophy is like oh you large
scale pre-training data and then you
have some kind of like alignment data or
like preference data that you know you
fine-tune on typically. Um I think that
holds true for uh a lot of other
modalities as well. It actually holds
true for video as well. So my background
I guess I didn't say was like you know I
did my PhD in general of AI at Stanford
was working a lot on like image video
models there as well. Um but in audio
it's actually quite interesting because
you know what people want from
preference data is actually so diverse
that it's like you know you can't
capture it purely by like a one one
stage fine-tuning step. So yeah you
definitely need very rich data you know
you need high quality data of course but
you also need to pair it uh with
information that like you know many many
different kind of people will want. So
uh you know this is how traditional LMS
are trained. I think a lot of the like
you know large open source you know uh
image generation video generation models
also are trained this way. Uh, but
honestly just really depends on what
you're trying to trying to get after.
But sorry, I don't know. I know that's
not a satisfying answer, but yeah.
What's your take on the speech to speech
models? I know Amazon has one. Seems
immature, I would say, but is that the
future or like what's happening? Yeah,
it's a it's a great question. Um, you
know, I think there are places where
like speech to speech is valuable right
now, but I don't think it's at the point
where we can actually use it for, you
know, production or enterprisegrade use
cases. Um, and you know, it's great, you
know, I think, you know, uh, Amazon
released the speech to speech model
recently. Um, you know, I think there's
a few others that are out there as well.
But I think it's still pretty clear that
like orchestrated solutions are places
that you get a lot of controllability
around like how you want the different
pieces of your system to operate. Um and
you know from a lat latency perspective
I think speech-to- speech models will of
course you know dominate over time but
uh I think that level of controllability
is something that needs to be thought of
from first principles when building
these systems right the goal of the
system is not to build something really
cute it's to build something that
actually functions for real world use
cases and we might not be there yet but
I I'm sure you know we'll get there over
time
yeah local models
100% yeah so at Cartisia like I said you
know we build for any device So uh we
have models that run locally on edge
devices. Um and you know I think it's
actually really important because you
know I think cloud models will always be
there right you know there's certain
size models certain capabilities like
you know that you get at like certain
sizes that you can't just you know get
you know fit on like I don't know very
very edge devices right like not even
like laptops but like if you get to like
smaller phones and things like that um
but there's a lot of applications where
you know edge devices are just critical
right uh I think the question becomes
like where is a network latency plus
cloud speed actually slower than edge
and we've broken that. So running our
models on edge are about five times
faster than if you were to roundtrip. Um
and so you get like just it's like
unparalleled latency that you get. Um
and I think that's quite exciting.
So we're almost up at time. We'll maybe
one more question. Sure. Yeah. Yeah. Um
so what tools do you recommend to
monitor basically the agent, right?
because you're going to be the one
that's we're going to call you.
Something's broken. It said pause three
seconds. Say pause three seconds, right?
So it can be like speech text.
Yeah, it can be I know something wrong
with AWS, but like how do you how do you
tell us like hey it's not us aggression
issue?
Yeah, that's a good question. Eval are
an incredibly important part of any
system that you build. Um how do we tell
you that? Uh, I guess you can message us
and ask us if it's a problem. Uh, but I
think what we found is, you know,
typically it's at the LM stage that we
see a lot of these issues. Um, you know,
you end up like, you know, oftentimes
there's like some level of formatting
that you need to do for outputs that
come from speech to text to make it like
viable for your LM and the outputs for
your LM to make it like, you know,
viable or ergonomic for your TTS to
handle. But we've actually handled a lot
of those edge cases for you. So over
time, you know, with Sonic 2, uh, you
know, I'm showing a slide here that's
like, you know, showing most on the
latency side, but a lot of the
capabilities and quality has also
improved substantially. So not only did
we get our models to be, you know, two
and a half times as fast as our initial
models, so we can get served at like 40
millisecond model latency, but a lot of
those, you know, edge case issues that
LM often run into, we know that you
don't want to deal with them. So we deal
with them, we deal with them for you to
making our system more robust. Got it.
So one more for me like it's 2025 now
think five years in the future 2030 if
you look back at what you've done over
the those past five years where is
Cartisia at where's voice AI at what do
you see yeah um you know I think voice
AI will be just like the deacto norm
right uh I think there in every industry
that you see you're going to have some
interaction with voice AI whether it's
on the triaging side the full end you
know support side you know gaming right
all of those interactions will will
definitely be you know large part, you
know, covered by voice AI. Uh, but I
don't think this is the only thing,
right? When you think about true
interactive models, it's more than just
what you can hear, right? It's about how
you experience the world around you,
right? So, you know, a lot of these
people call it like world models, right?
But I think actually getting these to
work in real time, I think will be
really exciting. And I'm I'm really
looking forward to like a world where,
you know, we can actually have these
kinds of systems work with us as, you
know, assistants or co-pilots or, you
know, whatever to actually help us
understand in the world in ways that we
couldn't imagine originally. Amazing.
Yeah. Well, thank you. I think that's
all we had today and really appreciate
it and thank you for sharing a little
bit about Yeah, appreciate it. Thanks,
guys.
[Music]